[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
an extravaganza is about to happen oh
yeah june 28th it's like you know it's
like christ rising it's insane you know
it's insane it's the second coming of
christ yeah
wonders of the world how many wonders of
were there huh how many wonders of the
world is seven we're the 12th we're the
12th wonder of the world june 28th
at 6 00 p.m guys 6 p.m pacific we've
never done this before we need your
support and you're going to be glad
you're there we've got so many good bits
planned we've got some people coming
into town to say hi to us yeah we might
have some things done to somebody
physically that they might not know
about yeah it's going to be incredible
surprises coming they're going to be
paying june 28th at 6 p.m
pacific time if you're not there
well we're going to be pissed
today is monday june 27th and there's
just one more day until bad friends goes
live the bad friends live show bobby lee
andrew santino they're doing it tomorrow
at 6 p.m it's gonna be fun you know the
few live podcasts i've seen in the past
have all over delivered what my
expectations were like the two bears one
i saw a few your mom's house ones and
live podcasts are they're awesome so i
definitely go recommend this if you are
a bad friend's fan if you're on the
fence so june 28th which is tomorrow
tuesday june 28th it starts at 6 p.m and
it goes till 9 pm so it's three hours
long and tickets for right now they're
12 bucks so you're paying four dollars
an hour to watch bobby lee andrew
santino and the rest of the bad friends
crew you know just do high high levels
of entertainment for you there it's
going to be funny i mean we can almost
guarantee that i'd say but also if you
wait till tomorrow or after to buy
tickets then they go up to 14 so today
is the last day that they're 12. and
then another cool thing they're doing is
that you can still buy tickets to this
for a week after the show so if you're
busy tomorrow night and you can't make
it at 6 p.m you could buy them any other
day this week or if you're wanting to
wait and get the word on the street and
see if it's worth it or not you could
wait a few days i'm definitely pulling
the trigger though and i want to watch
live with them because i think that
there's something a little more uh
humorous about it when you know that
it's happening actually live rather than
watching a taped live version back i
don't know i guess it's technically the
same thing but i think i'm i'm going to
be there tomorrow at 6 pm so let me know
comment if you're gonna be there comment
if you're going to the virtual live show
uh tomorrow at 6 p.m and they also have
this live chat going right now for
people that are waiting so if you're a
huge bad friends fan and just want to
get real into the community go check
that out too
bad friends live show tomorrow june 28th
i'm excited go to momenthouse.com bad
friends to sign up to watch this live
show it's a christian life it's a
christian live show it's all it's going
to be i'm getting baptized
i'm baptizing you i your baptism made by
joseph's nice joseph smith exactly
yes and it's gonna be great so watch bad
friends live you can you can watch it
from your couch from the bathtub from a
spaceship yeah you can you can watch
from anywhere it's a christian only show
tom segura's new book came out last week
very exciting it's called i'd like to
play alone please and it is hilarious i
would definitely recommend it i bought
mine on amazon and it came i think i
pre-ordered it so i got it about a week
ago but it's hilarious it's it's funny
it's sad it's uh insightful it's it
sounds like tom i mean
this is the first sentence of the book
so you guys can get a taste to see if
it's worth the read for you
very first sentence of the book a note
from the author
when jeffrey epstein called me in the
summer of 2013 i didn't know what to
make of it we had spent time together in
paris the prior spring
that's really what it says right there
and it just picks up from there i mean
that's how it starts and it keeps going
they told me
that
there was a couple things in the book
that we shouldn't keep in the book
and i was like why and they said
you're definitely going to get flagged
for this from like the book world
as being like
you know
highly offensive
and uh
and i was like oh i'm ready
like
i live in this world not in the book
world so let them
i don't know if it'll happen but they
seem to think that there's stuff in the
book that will uh
upset people
i don't know i mean
like i said i'm about halfway done with
it so i'll give a full book review
probably next comedy update next week
but tom sagora's book i mean the artwork
is cool there's pictures in here there's
stories um some of the favorite stories
from a stand-up like the lost wallet to
stories about his dad to stories about
just everything there was that voice
where i was like oh i wanted to do that
too i've seen comedians with books for
years and i always wondered if it would
be you know something that i would do
it's things from everywhere like
childhood stories um
stories about the podcast stories about
being a touring comedian
the one about my father the one about my
mother
um people that i've met celebrities like
it's kind of a mix of everything that
that um i thought was either interesting
or funny to write about and i think it
turned out you know pretty well i think
the audiobook will be a lot of fun for
podcasts and stand-up fans to listen to
not only that but it was also number two
on the new york times bestseller list so
now tom score is forever a new york
times best-selling author which is kind
of funny and kind of cool it's awesome
go get this book tom segura i'd like to
play alone please if you're a timescore
fan you'll definitely really enjoy it i
just got the call it's very exciting
i am a new york times bestseller
thank you very much
and i'm number two on the list some
[ __ ]
absolute
[ __ ] bag of a human being i'm sure
i don't know i don't know who it is
number one [ __ ] that guy
but it is fun to say i'm number two
also welcome back to the comedy world
update every single monday bringing you
the comedy news that you need to know
right here on joke world so make sure
you subscribe if you haven't and tune in
every single monday we're gonna go
through topics happening in the comedy
world right now uh who went on each
other's shows who's dropping new
specials anything and everything that
you need to know about the world of
stand-up comedians and just comedy in
general the comedy world update every
single monday stavros announced on
saturday that he is leaving the podcast
come town posting this on his instagram
to let the fans know
he said want to let everyone know that
i'm not a part of come town anymore as
much as we joked about hating the fans
in the podcast itself the show changed
my life and i'll always be grateful for
that thanks to everyone who listened
subscribed and supported the show it
means a lot i'm sad my involvement in
the pod is over but i'm also really
excited for the future i'm working on a
couple things and i can't wait to share
love ya thanks for everything and the
caption was we had a good run with two
hearts so stavros leaving come town it
sounds like things will move forward
with the podcast maybe without him and
it doesn't seem to be any bad blood the
vibe in the community section um when i
posted this talking about it
with you guys is that you know stavros
is hot right now wants to capitalize off
of everything he's got going for him and
people are happy for both sides so
end of come town as we know it we'll see
what happens with it in the future um
but thank you stavros for the great
memories there and uh hopefully things
continue to keep working out in the
future i mean he's one of the hottest
comedians he's my favorite actual
stand-up to watch on stage i'd say with
these clips that he's putting out so i'm
sure it's all going to work out for
everyone but just kind of sad for the uh
lifelong fans of of cometown now it's
time for the guest list which is where
we go through who went on each other's
shows last week to make sure you don't
miss any comedians appearing on any
podcast that you really would like to
enjoy so this past weekend did not have
a guest this week tiger belly had on
oliver tree
two bears one cave had danny brown sit
in instead of burnt chrysler flagrant ii
who has been on a absolute podcast
heater unlike we've ever seen before
they had on stevo and dave portnoy last
week which is just incredible i feel
like every single time we've been doing
these comedy updates i keep saying oh my
gosh these flagrant like guests are just
insane they've had joe rogan logan paul
dave portnoy stevo um
stavros they've had in all within like
lined up with each other so flagrant too
can or i mean flagrant now it's just
flagrant now sorry flagrant continues to
kill it
with their guests whiskey ginger head on
jessica kirsten uh kill tony tonight
features polly shore and then i don't
know if you've been on social media at
all last week but joe rogan and the
protector parks they got after it with
mark norman shane gillis and ari shafir
ari trying to challenge outdrink shane
and he had 17 beers on the podcast and
just kind of passed away and threw up
into a cooler but there's been a ton of
funny memes about it this is one of the
best groups to ever get together behind
the mics i'd go check out the jre
protect our parks every time they get
together and this one was one of the
best ones and then lastly tom segura was
on we might be drunk with mark norman
and sam morrell always good to have tom
on as a guest um so check that one out
as well then there's like clubs that you
just you personally have so much comfort
in
so like uh
the brea improv for me is where i like
first did a feature set whoa what did
you feature for
uh
actually the very first time was cosby i
got i got promoted during the weekend oh
bad host
well had it had a rough go okay it was a
tell
wow yeah
what yeah
wow holy [ __ ] well that's gotta feel
good to get promoted yeah it was with a
tail
yeah the king and i was like
super [ __ ]
like like a child like like you know
like a kid with like lebron i was like
like staring at him
he's like do you ever blink like feel
like that you know the green room and
like he gets more shout outs on this
podcast than i think any comic i have a
[ __ ] like whole chapter about him
you know that's my first time featuring
a weekend for the improvs and for anyone
and i was like you know i was like i'm a
feature now like it was amazing right
and then i started to get work from them
like that and then
the next year so like a year has gone by
i get a call i'm working a day job
they're like hey um do you want to work
like this coming weekend at the uh
improv and bray i was like yeah sure
they go you've been requested
and i was like oh by who and you go and
they go dave attell and i'm like wow
right so i was like [ __ ] yes
so
i'm working the weekend and i'm like now
i'm a little more
confident and
i start you know
where i think we do like thursday show
and then after the first show friday
we're in the green room
and he was like uh
you don't have like a you don't have 20
new minutes i was like what
and he's like
i mean you did some of those jokes last
year and i was like
oh
yeah i guess he goes i mean do you want
to be like an actor or something oh my
god from him hearing it from him you
could tell this yeah that is wow
i mean kind of yeah
as far as new specials go there weren't
too many last week to really report on
uh joey avery had a set come out on
comedy central that's really funny i
definitely go check him out on instagram
and go check out his new comedy central
set and if you want some more joey avery
go check out his episode of the joke
world podcast that we did besides that
though this has been another episode of
the joke world comedy update every
single monday bringing you all the news
in the comedy space so please subscribe
if you like these videos and you can
download them just the audio on spotify
or apple wherever you listen to podcasts
if you wanted to listen to this on the
go if you just want a quick catch up of
and refresher of everything that's
happening in comedy but thank you again
make sure you subscribe the channel go
follow us on instagram and i'll see you
guys next monday
[Music]
you